welcome to exploring computing
today's video is web page layout
overview of layout techniques so in this
video we're going to take a look at four
different ways to layout your web pages
two of these are currently in widespread
use one of them
is therefore stark reasons and to
compare to
our fourth method and to sort of
highlight what's really great about the
fourth method
and then the fourth method is the future
of web page layout
but probably isn't as widely used yet
as the middle two techniques i'm
actually going to recommend you use the
fourth technique unless you've got a
good reason not to
so let's take a look at these so the
first
technique is table based layout this is
no longer in use but as i said
by comparing table-based layout to our
fourth
method grid-based layout you're going to
really see what the advantage of using
cascading style sheets is and why grid
based layout is a great way to go
the second technique we're going to talk
about is float based layout
this has been for many many years the
most widely used technique out there
i just did a quick spot check and for
example the washington post
is using float based layout right now
our third technique flexbox layout
has picked up a little bit of momentum
in the last maybe three years or so
i don't think it's a great choice it's
good to know about and
the techniques used in flexbox are going
to be useful for a variety of purposes
but i don't really think you should use
this as your main layout technique that
was not the intention originally when it
was developed
people have sort of used it as a hack
i i don't think it's the best um
i really do think this last one the
grid-based layout is definitely the way
to go
so um but you know the two most commonly
used techniques right now are float
based layout and flexbox layout so
if you come on to an existing uh web
page
those are the two techniques you're most
likely to run into
the other thing to be aware of is that
one of the reasons
why grid based layout even though it's
really great isn't in widespread usage
yet
is that it's only been recently
that all the web browsers are supporting
it and at this point
um about 95 of the web browsers out
there support it
so you may still run into a few web
browsers that that
can't use it um flexbox layout
has about 97 support and then float
based layout and table based loud
everybody can use
but don't use table based layout
okay we're going to go over three
examples for each of these four
techniques to sort of
give us a chance to see how they work
i'm not actually going to be showing you
any html or css
in this particular video but we will
take an extensive look at
grid layout in the next video and then
for the cs105 students we're going to
have a full lecture where we look at a
bunch of different examples
and i recreate parts of the new york
times website and parts of the
washington post website using grid-based
layout so you can get a real good feel
for how it all works
okay so our first example is going to be
this simple three column web page right
here
and then we're going to take a look at
this web page that has a mix of
different column formats so we'll have a
three columns up at the top and two
columns down at the bottom
and then finally our last examples you
can have this
rather mixed layout here where you know
it's not like there's
two columns on the top and three on the
bottom
it's really kind of a jumble and so
we'll see how each of the different
layout techniques handles
each of these three cases all right so
table based layout is based on the
concept of tables and so
tables have been in html from the start
we talked previously about
how html came out of physics
the cern physics consortium
out in europe and uh you know they were
trying to exchange physics papers
and one of the things that you need for
physics is table so we've had tables
from the start and so
basically for quite a while we use these
tables to
lay out our web pages i'll talk a little
bit later about why this isn't the best
approach but
um so let's say i've got these uh i want
to go ahead and reproduce my three
column
website how can i do this well if you
think about it this three column website
is just
it's a table where there's one row and
three columns so it's actually really
straightforward uh
recreating this using table based layout
and then we've got our
table here with different top and bottom
sections
all right so there's a couple ways to do
this so
one thing that you can do is you can
nest your table so we have
one table which consists of a single
column in two
rows and then within that first
table you have a another table which is
a
three column one row table and then at
the bottom you have a
two column one row table or
you can have a single table where you
have four columns and two rows
and then you can take advantage of the
column span
uh attributes to get some of your
elements to span across multiple columns
so each of these
approaches will work fine and then
finally we have this mixed layout here
and so again i think the easiest way to
think about this is to think of nesting
and so one of the things that's going to
occur with all these techniques is you
can use
nesting so you can say oh i'm going to
go ahead and treat this
as a layout where i have a column on the
left and a column on the right
and then you can go in and say well in
that column on the right i need to lay
that out
and so you can do a separate internal
layout for the right column
and that's a good way of going about
these things so i can think of this
whole thing as
i have a two column one row table
and then on the right column i could say
inside of that table i actually have
another table
and that table is one column in two rows
and then you can take it a further level
and you can say and the second row
actually contains another table which is
two columns in one row
and this all works but this is actually
one of the reasons why
we aren't really doing table layout
anymore and that is as you start nesting
the tables
it becomes more and more computational
expensive and slower to do
layout so generally three layers of
tables was just fine but once you
started getting four or five or six
layers of tables it started getting kind
of messy and
the web browsers were not very happy
with it there are other reasons why uh
this isn't the best approach although
some of these issues will also crop up
with the next two techniques as well
okay so instead of treating this as
a table nest inside of table nest inside
of a table you could also treat this as
a three column two row table
and then use row span and call span and
that could work as well
and you know depending on what you were
trying to do
one of these or the other one might work
better
but we're not going to worry about that
in this video either of these techniques
would work
so what are the issues with table based
layout well one of the biggest issues
is that the tables are in our html so
when we create our html we are defining
what our layout looks like
in the html and so we're really locking
ourselves into
a particular layout and if we want to
change the layout at a later point time
let's say i wanted to change the layout
for
all the web pages on my website i would
need to go in and modify
each of the html files because the html
files has the layout
encoded in the tables in those html
files instead of being separated out
from our cascading style sheets
remember that's what we said we really
want to have the presentation
information on the cascading style sheet
so i can modify the cascading style
sheet and it instantly changes
all the web pages on our website and
that doesn't work with
tables and in fact we're going to
discover it doesn't work with the next
two techniques either
and then as i mentioned uh the nested
tables can become computational
expensive
okay so we use the table based layout
for many many years
uh but um when we started using
cascading style sheets another technique
came into
uh before and that's this float based
layout
and float based layout is still used
quite a bit um
and you will run into many websites that
are using float based layouts so how
does float based layout work well the
first thing to remind ourselves is
what is this idea of float and so we've
talked about float before in this class
we talked about floating images so
here on the left i've got an image of
venice i floated to the left and then
i've got
text alongside on the right and then
we did this example where we had images
with captions underneath it
and in that case i wasn't actually
floating the image i was actually
floating some divs
where the div contained both the image
and the caption underneath it but again
we would float those to the left to the
right
and as i mentioned very briefly when we
were talking about float
you can float any block level element
and so here i've got a block quote and
i've
floated the block quote to the left and
you can see it's doing the exact same
thing that our images did when we
floated them to the left to the right
and so we can actually float
multiple images and that will actually
stack the images
next to each other if i float two images
to left and you know assuming they fit
they will end up right next to each
other and i can do the same thing here
with these block quotes so what i've
done here is i've added a second block
quote
and i've told both the block quests to
float to the left
and they end up right next to each other
just as our original
they had a single block quote we floated
that to left now we've got two
block quotes and we floated those both
to the left
um and if you kind of think about what
these two block quotes are doing here
float to the left
well those are essentially columns and
so
i can get rid of the text other than the
two block quotes
and this is what i have and so i have
two columns
and you know if you've looked at any web
page they all are composed of different
columns so this is really the key to
to laying out web pages using floats we
go ahead and create these different
columns and we float them
to the left and so
um i was using block quotes i can
replace the block codes with divs
and you can put basically any renderable
element inside of a div so
here i've got two divs both floated to
the left
and so if we go to our three examples
if i want to layout my three columns i
just go ahead and create three divs
and then i float each of the divs to the
left it is possible to mix floating to
the left and floating to the right
but that gets messy in certain
situations it can also be useful in
certain situations but if you just float
everything to the left
you can basically create any web page
consisting of
different columns
okay so what about our example where we
have
a mix of three columns on the top and
two on the bottom
how am i going to handle this well what
you're going to do is you're first going
to divide the web page
into two divs and these are just
standard divs and the standard behavior
of
a div followed by another div is to
stack the two divs on top of each other
and then what we're going to do is we're
going to put a bunch of divs inside of
one of those standard divs and instead
of just using the standard behavior
div we're going to float those to left
just as we did a little bit earlier
and then we'll do the same thing on the
bottom we'll create two diffs down on
the bottom it will float those both to
the left
as well and we'll actually get what
what we're expecting here what we're
looking for here
it does turn out there's a bit of
messiness which i'm going to completely
ignore for this discussion
um you know if you do want to use
float-based layout
uh the benefit of using the float-based
layout being that it does work in 100 of
the web browsers out there whereas
our next two techniques um you'll recall
that the next technique works in 97
of the web browsers and the final
technique only works in 95 of the web
browsers float based will work on all of
them
um okay so what about our mixed example
here
well again what we want to do is we want
to think of the nesting so i'm going to
have two divs here
and i'm going to float both the divs to
the left and that's going to give me
this concept of two columns
so i've got one column i've got the red
column and then i have the light blue
column
and then in the light blue column i'm
going to create two divs
and remember if you've got divs and
you're not floating the divs that stacks
the divs on top of each other so
i've got these two div stacked on top of
each other
and then the bottom div i'm going to put
another two divs in i'm going to float
those both to the left and that's how i
get this all to work
so the issues with float based layout
is it's still pretty tied to the html so
in order to get these columns floated to
the left
i need to create the divs in exactly the
right manner so i can
move the elements in a particular way
such that they do stack up next to each
other so
um it turns out that
my html still is very closely tied to
the layout
you can't just change the css and
have a completely new web page you can
make some changes but for the most part
the html and the divs that you choose
and how you place the divs
is going to really drive how the web
page appears on
uh in the web browser there's also some
messy issues which i'm completely
ignoring here
in order to get all these diffs to work
properly
they can certainly be handled or
techniques to handle them but it's not
quite as
clean as as i may have led you to
believe
in our discussion here but nevertheless
this technique um
is very widely used and has been has
been the main technique used on web
pages for
for quite a while now
uh the next technique uses something
called flexbox so let's
start off by talking a little bit about
what flexbox is
so flexbox is designed to take a bunch
of divs
that are contained inside of a parent
div and sort of to control
what those inner divs look like so one
of the
one of the key things that you can do
with this those
inner child divs is you can control
whether or not they appear in a row or a
column
so um here i've got a row of divs and
then i can just
easily change it to column of dips just
by changing one stylesheet property
and there's some fancy things you can do
as well so i um
you know so here i'm actually showing
the parent div so i've got a b
c and d contained with an apparent div
so a b c and d are divs
and they're contained in a parent div
and so you can see i can move the divs
to left i can move them to the right i
can move to the middle i can spread them
out
and so these are all different things
that you can do very easily just by
changing a stylesheet property
you can also say hey if the divs fit
great if they don't fit i want to wrap
or
you could say if they don't fit i want
you to like squeeze them in there
um and so there's different things that
you can do with with the
uh the child divs you can select certain
child divs and say hey if we've got the
extra space i want that to expand out to
take the
maximum amount of space available and
you can play with the alignment
um so
if you kind of think about what we've
seen so far
you may be wondering like how does that
you know that seems
useful but that doesn't really
seem to lay out web pages and that
certainly was the original intention the
intention was that
flexbox layout was not designed to
actually lay out web pages
i think what happened was people were
really sick of the float based layout
and it was messy and you had in it and
all this extra stuff in your html
and flexbox layout
came along and people were like great
i'm just going to use it
you know maybe this isn't what it was
originally 10 or 4 but i'm going to use
it anyway
so what was flexbox layout actually
intended for
well flexbox and grid based layout which
is going to be our last technique
both flexbox and grid were defined at
roughly the same time and the idea was
that
you were going to use a mix of grid
layout and flexbox layout to layout your
web pages
the grid layout was going to be used for
the major components
and sort of figure out how everything
overall is going to fit together and you
could use flexbox for
smaller components so what i mean by
that well
here i've got a screenshot of the
washington post
and you can see on the right side of the
webpage i've got
a bunch of different opinions and so
the opinions could be laid out using
flexbox
and the overall look of the web page
would be laid out with grid
and then so here's another example where
we've got this center section
called for your time at home and again
overall web page could be laid out with
grid and then the
four year time at home that could be a
little bit of a
flex flexbox right there and so we
haven't really talked about it but
among other things flexbox could also be
used to set different ordering of
elements so
you know if uh
let's say they knew that you really
liked chocolate
and there were a bunch of recipes and
one of them was chocolate they could
sort of
tweak the style sheet using uh
javascript
uh and put the chocolate recipes at the
top and so this is a sort of thing that
you could do with flexbox
so again flexbox is useful
um i certainly would am not suggesting
that you
if you're gonna go off and create web
pages that you shouldn't know how
flexbox works
but as far as flexbox being used for the
entire web page layout
i don't think it's the ideal choice um
okay so let's take a look at how
flexbox is used for layout so we've got
our three columns here
so this is pretty straightforward uh i
need a outer div because flexbox always
use
works with a parent div and then a bunch
of child did so i'm gonna go ahead and
create the parent div
and then inside the parent div i'm gonna
go ahead and put three children
um three divs that are children and then
i'm going to tell it to use the flexbox
row and so that says those three
children should be laid out in a row as
opposed to being laid out of the column
so that definitely works for our messier
technique here
the uh upper and lower um
columns three and two it gets a little
bit messier though so
i'm going to start off by saying okay
the entire thing
um that's a div you know we've
seen this before that's that has this
useful property that we can use to
center everything
and then inside of that div i have two
children
and those children are going to be laid
out in column
and then each of those children are also
going to contain
their own children and they will be laid
out in rows
so i can do this on the top and the
bottom so that that works
and then for our mixed example here
again i'm going to go with this idea of
nesting and so i've got the outer div
and it has two children and those are
laid out as rows
and then the second child that has
two divs and those are laid out as
columns and then the second
child the second child has two more divs
and those are laid out in rows so this
does work
um the issues involved here are as we're
still
fairly tied to the html we can do some
things
where you know the html is already set
up
and we can change the direction so this
actually
could work pretty well for you think
about like if i've got a desktop
monitor maybe i want to lay things out
in a row but if
it's going to be on a cell phone that's
going to be really narrow so i want them
to appear in column
so you can do some things with it but
the changes are pretty limited and we
are still
limited by the idea that certain
elements are contained within certain
other elements and that's going to
really
determine what we can do with our
cascading style sheet so we can do
something with the cascading style
sheets but overall
a lot of it is still limited by what's
specified in html
okay so we've got our last technique
here grid layout
in grid layout we break down the web
page into a grid and then we place
elements
onto any square in the grid and you can
also do the row span on the column span
if you want to get fancier so
you know if you want to say oh i want
that element to go
across uh these two grid elements
that's totally fine if you want to say
an omelet goes across multiple row
elements that
that's fine as well and in the next
video we're actually going to show you
how this all works because this is a
this is a technique i'm going to
recommend that you use
okay so for grid layout um our first
example
this is just a three column by one row
grid
and then for our next example
you can either do the nesting with one
column two row grid
and then two inner grids or
you can create a four column two row
grid
and then our last example we can again
either do the inners
uh you know with an outer grid and then
a bunch of inner grids
or you can do the three column by two
row grid
and if you've been paying attention
uh and you remember what i was talking
about a little earlier about how the
table worked
you may be thinking this looks exactly
like the table
and in fact i was overjoyed about this
part of the
drawings because i did not have to
redraw
anything for the grid-based layout i
just took the table based layout
drawings and i replaced the word
table with grid so one column two row
table becomes
one column two row grid so
we started off with the table layout uh
way back when
and are we back to the same thing as we
started with
well here's the thing in table based
layout
the table is in the html
it's not in the cascading style sheet so
if we want to make changes to the layout
we need to go in and modify that table
in the html
and similarly if you saw the floats you
know there's a bunch of stuff going on
with the float and that's
more or less tied to the html you can
make some changes maybe
you can float something to the right
instead of the left but really you're
going to be largely limited to
how the html is written and again with
the
flexbox you again you are going to be
greatly limited by what you wrote in the
html
this is not the case with the grid based
layout
so i can define the grid and the
cascading style sheets
if i want one grid for a desktop
computer with a large screen
a different grid for a tablet a third
grid for
a cell phone that's totally fine i can
define as many grids as we want
cs105 students we'll talk about this
next week when we talk about responsive
web design
cs106e students sorry guys you're gonna
miss out uh but i will put up the 105
lectures if any of you are interested in
that
um and so you know we can define all
sorts of grids for all sorts of
different uses
in our cascading style sheets and then
we can place any element
anywhere we want on this grid we are
completely
unlimited by the html
as long as i have a bunch of divs in my
html or or
for that matter any other block elements
and i give them ids
i can take any of those elements that i
gave them an id and i can place them
in any grid from the cascading style
sheet so this gives us complete
flexibility
to reorder and redesign
and modify using just the cascading
style sheets with no changes to the html
at all so
i think this is just a huge win uh
i i just think that this technique is
great uh
i definitely think it's the future um
really the only downside and this is
becoming less and less of an issue
five percent of the web browsers out
there are not going to be able to use it
now i will say when i first saw this
technique i thought it was
really great and i started teaching it
in my 193c
class that's a class for on web
development for majors
and i taught it i taught it for a couple
years
and it still was largely unsupported by
any of the web browsers this is stuff
for internet explorer
chrome kind of had a version that kind
of worked for a while
it was just it did not look like what's
going to happen but
it's finally happening you know 95 of
the web browsers now support this
this technique is great it gives you
great flexibility
it's way easier to understand than float
i think it's easier to understand the
flexbox like
yeah you can't understand what the
flexbox is doing on an individual
section scale but then when you try and
lay out the entire web page with flexbox
it just gets kind of nasty
grid layout is just great i'm just a
huge fan and so this is the technique
i'm going to recommend
you all learn the only downside would be
if you're trying to create a website
right now
think about who your audience is and
think about whether or not they have
modern web browsers so
you know if you're doing something that
where maybe
your audience might not have modern web
browsers then
maybe this isn't a technique you want to
use but otherwise
i think it's definitely the way to go
this is a great technique all right so
in the next lecture we're going to
actually show you how this technique
works
uh we're going to teach you how to
create the css for it and how to put
elements on the web page
i'll see you then